[Applause]
and
i think the place that needs to
spearhead this movement is
uh ontario canada oh yes
yeah a few canadians in it my family's
there
they are miserable son they are
it is unbelievable what's happening
right now yeah it's unbelievable what's
happening right now
in canada uh they are locked down yet
again i guess they can't get vaccines
right keep that [ __ ] keep that same
energy with your healthcare talks
keep your same energy with your [ __ ]
healthcare talks next time around all
right we're gonna remind you this whole
[ __ ]
i think they can't get it because we
aren't sending them yeah some [ __ ] like
that moms are trying to explain it yeah
like we snatched a bunch when we were
like oh whoa whoa we actually need them
shits yeah yeah
we call dibs i think mm-hmm yeah when
you make the [ __ ] maybe you get to call
dibs yeah we said shotgun and what the
[ __ ] is bernie sanders talking all this
[ __ ] in canada
they don't need those drugs they need
the vaccine and they don't got him now
bernie's quiet right now about how cheap
drugs are in canada how much a vaccine
goes for
how much of johnson johnson we're about
to send you to johnson johnson's
is that the one that's [ __ ] up yeah
we're about to send you them johnson
johnson's that's what you're gonna get
canada yeah
have you all looking like hey you guys
we're gonna
hey you guys out there okay
anyway point is ontario's lock the [ __ ]
down and i think you need to open it
down
full lockdown yo it's on some like
nazi [ __ ] almost they basically have
given cops the authority to just stop
cars and like ask them for proof that
they have permission to leave the house
you're out past like eight o'clock you
have to have a valid reason you can get
fined like five grand immediate fine
right there it's unbelievable what
they're doing to these people
when and this is the conversation that
we got to start to have right is that
you have places like
texas florida fully open people going to
sporting events
and numbers are going down yeah at what
point
does the lockdown become anti-science
their argument this whole time is we
trust the science we trust the science
[ __ ] is out there no lockdown
no mask
my girl did a barry's boot camp this
morning no masks in the class
science is right say what you couldn't
go because your arms yeah man
yeah i'm not gonna be picking up the
heavies no i can't pick up the heavies
bro i gotta do double tread
i can't switch and do them weights don't
yeah
does it become anti-science i think
there might be something to
places where warm weather have less uh
cases of corona period but if that's the
case you got to look at why is it just
vitamin d
i bet everybody take [ __ ] supplements
for a month or whatever and then we just
live and open it up like
figure out you can't just look at one
aspect of the science and be like all
right well
we got to lock down yeah look at the
whole picture it's not doesn't seem that
hard to me
yeah yeah i i mean it's just
mind-boggling to me man especially with
canada
and i don't know if we were talking
about this on patreon but like these
[ __ ] get three weeks
of sunshine duck yeah like that's
literally what they get like summer is
short in canada yeah like very short i
mean i'm being sarcastic but i'm
actually not
we're talking about two months where
it's like legit summer and then it's
back
yeah and even at the end of summer it
starts to get a little cool so
they need summer yeah these people have
been locked down for a year they're
gonna go [ __ ] crazy
yeah i don't feel the same way about
like texas or florida if you want to
lock them down these people have like
houses with pools and [ __ ] this doesn't
really feel like lockdown in canada you
live in ontario
you were in an apartment building for a
[ __ ] year 13 months 14 months 15
months
if they come back to next fall next
winter people are gonna kill themselves
out there yo
you gonna have more deaths from suicide
alcohol depression than you will from
coronavirus i mean we're already seeing
how crazy [ __ ] is
after lockdown in america [ __ ] is nuts
oh you mean like partying
partying [ __ ] everybody's out there
the whoring 20s that's what they said
i think it's backfiring a little bit in
canada because they've been in lockdown
so long
they're having a lot of house parties
like i see which makes it even worse
think about that because people are in
close quarters it can't just be one
one solution oh cases are up lock
everything down you can't do the same
[ __ ] four times in order if it hasn't
worked
you know what i mean it didn't work the
first time didn't work the second time
hey let's keep doing it
the science no science says if a [ __ ]
experiment fails you try something else
you tweak it somehow
that's the science so you can't just get
hey the science let's go back to the
first thing that [ __ ] up
i guess they did tweak it though they
made it harder yeah they made the
lockdown more
restrictive like they pushed up the
curfew time like yeah your point they
did tweak it where they were like all
right it didn't work last time let's
make it more strict
yeah and it is crazy to see a a place
like canada
and i'm not trying to like insult them
as liberal [ __ ]
but like government overreach bro
it is it is interesting though because
like they are a far more compliant
culture than americans are yeah right
like americans you tell us to do
anything
we say [ __ ] you we grab a gun and then
we go to the statehouse country's legit
born in rebellion this country
yes it's in our blood in our dna and the
people that come here rebelled from
their country yeah that's all we are is
a bunch of [ __ ] rebels so if you try
to get us to join anything we're gonna
lose our
[ __ ] mind okay canada
not the same right like i've said this
plenty of times before but they still
got the queen on their money like
they're really not giving much pushback
right like
you got the queen on your money like
push back on that bare minimum
yeah bare minimum so the fact that
they're reaching that breaking point the
fact that i got people in the [ __ ]
dms
non-stop going yo it's crazy what's
happening right here right now and i'm
talking about liberal concern it doesn't
matter we're not talking about like the
oil parts
of canada it's getting into like the
scary zone where people are like yeah
it's like i didn't think that our
government would do this to us
and that was the trust that they had in
their government and what's really
interesting is like
what how did they get out of this
because the trust they had in our their
government was
i'm in a truck it's like a babysitter
i'm gonna trust you with my kids don't
molest them
yeah the second the babysitter touch of
the kids you don't trust no babysitters
anymore ever
yeah right you broke the trust and
that's what they had with the
with their government they're like hey
we'll do anything you say
because we trust that you have our best
interests at heart and to be fair to
canada
for the most part they did throughout
history right yeah at least for their
country i can't look at these like
and of course how they treat native
americans and and i'm sure how they
treated
people of color has been [ __ ] up i'm
not talking about that i'm talking about
like give us your tax money and we'll
make sure school's affordable give us
your tax money we'll make sure you have
healthcare like
they had a pretty good symbiotic
relationship yeah
this is egregious and i don't know if
you can rebound from this yeah i think
that
i think you just created some rebels bro
i think you just created
you have you a family there right a
whole majority in toronto and
they're with trudeau right now who's a
liberal before they were with harper
it doesn't matter what side you are you
liberal courted the system of like
canada
healthcare for the most part and just
everything that was uh going on
not anymore not anymore i'm telling you
mark you're canadian yeah
yeah like that's the thing it is wow
you're canadian huh yeah
i'm a [ __ ] liberal dude my dad's
canadian
no but it's like i'm assuming that all
of the measures are actually enforced
like even being in new york
they we had like curfews and stuff like
that and people would call me being like
man it must be crazy right
yeah i mean like the rule is you can't
go out but like you can go out yeah it's
like jaywalking yeah i'm walking up the
street you know i mean like it wasn't
actually really enforced so i'm assuming
that
in canada it actually is enforced like
the things we're hearing about are as
bad as they actually are
like that's one thing that i'm like i
need to be sure on
but i don't know it just seems like it's
those types of lockdowns that people
were like nah it's not gonna get bad
until it's bad and like part of the
conversation like we were having here is
like
it gets bad and then people are locked
in their houses again fine for going
outside assuming that's what's actually
happening yeah
yeah i don't know it's frustrating like
it's a good example of like how
things can creep up and like how people
can actually be restricted by
governments going crazy with power
yeah what is interesting though is
india's on a full line they're the guys
of safety
by the way that's the that's the
trickiest thing yeah
and it is always under the guise of
safeties we're doing this to protect you
we're doing this protect you well i
don't necessarily think they have
nefarious intentions
but i do think it might not they just
look at a thing one way
yeah and they're like all right all
right well that didn't work the first
time let's do more of it it's like bro
you should be more creative thinkers
a year later they have to be having a
different answer like saying like okay
let's just lock up the vulnerable yeah
you're out and
that's what at least you should be to
the point they won't say it they don't
want to say it
it might not be nefarious i'm not like
saying that the government's trying to
control their people and hurt them
yeah they're legitimately trying to
treat the problem but the solution is by
restricting people's freedoms and not
letting people go out
and it is working probably like numbers
are probably going down because people
are trapped in their house for 16 hours
yeah that's going to make numbers go
down and it's going to affect a lot of
other [ __ ] but it's gonna make numbers
go down so like if that's their only
objective then
they're probably succeeding in that
regard but to me it's like a
infringement on like human liberty and
like what
human beings are supposed to be doing
well at a certain point in time you
can't you're gonna break a human spirit
but like especially
yeah cause that's the things like if
everybody's locked down we've spoken
about this earlier when it came to like
doing a stand-up again right
yeah like we were sitting around i think
it was all of us but we were just like
yo do you guys like miss stand up
and we're like yeah i miss it but like
no one else is doing it so it's kind of
okay yeah right you know like it almost
feels like a christmas like
when everybody's not working i don't
feel any pressure to work yeah but if
i'm just taking a random thursday off
i'm like whoa is everybody out there
getting it yeah and i'm missing
you know so like i feel like the fact
that texas is open as [ __ ]
florida is open like you're seeing your
sports team
you're the toronto raptors you're seeing
people at
the stadium for your sports team and you
can't even leave your house
yeah that's when [ __ ] starts to drive
you a little crazy and the daily death
rate across the entire country
yesterday's 32 people this whole
last two weeks it's been under 100 it's
never but it's usually based on like
hospitalization
and and when the hospital numbers get to
a certain extent yeah like beds
and all of that but they're still you
know who's vulnerable you need to start
focusing on protecting those
doug ford you need to call up [ __ ]
texas professor x what's that
motherfucker's name
oh [ __ ] abbott greg you need to call up
abbott and you just find out what the
[ __ ] he's doing over there
and also shout out to his daughter his
daughter is kind of a pair
oh great oh it's kind of happening
[Music]
nah dude she got a rig bro whoa
really i don't know she got the full rig
yeah she got a rig dude jordan used that
when we're working i use that term and i
guess
i was like yeah that's a cool term
you're saying beauty over here
they've got weird like slangs yeah
because all the slang has to do with
like workout things
to you beauty what he says that to me
all the time beauty i'm like what's
beauty am i beauty
oh oh like the move that you did was
beautiful yeah yeah but you won't say
beautiful just say beauty
yo did you just change the topic from
tits to you working
i was working out just mine ain't going
nowhere what's the problem
what is that so yeah crack that [ __ ]
open yo
open her up y'all should be playing that
[ __ ] non-stop in canada
i want instead of seven o'clock clapping
out your window
i want you to be blasting open her up
out your windows
yeah encounter something else clap
something else what is it
their hands clap your hands well no
play opener up sing this [ __ ] out your
apartment windows out your condos out
your houses out whatever the [ __ ] it is
you got in ontario
slap that [ __ ] that is your anthem right
now also
ours um and yeah man it's
it's just crazy it's just crazy to see
corona be so [ __ ] done down here in
florida
and like it starts to crack open in
other places like new york is
is kind of looking lit right now you
were back there this weekend right
a little fire wet it's it's nice they
still have the curfew i think they're
extending it uh this week
so yeah it's good like i love that
they're extending it but it's also
so insulting that like the chimp nipple
sauce monkey governor can go
you can stay out to nine now i mean
they're still doing that here
what that's my best
everything shuts down at midnight you
can be out but everything yeah but let's
why they did it right spring break is
[Applause]
done
you